joe biden is running out of options
he can't keep hiding from the american
people that hurts his poll numbers
but he can't keep talking either because
that also hurts his poll numbers he can
no longer talk about afghanistan
immigration the economy
abortion election integrity or even the
coronavirus which used to help his poll
numbers but now like all those other
issues hurts them
so the only thing he's got
to help boost his popularity
is to stoke fears of the sun monster
for decades
scientists have warned of extreme
weather
would be more extreme and climate change
was here and we're living through it now
we don't have any more time
i hope no one
i've been on the telephone or on the
road
an awful lot
between
california
idaho
new orleans excuse not new orleans
louisiana but new orleans mississippi
and you know here i mean every part of
the country
every part of the country is getting hit
by extreme weather
and we're now living in real time
what the country is going to look like
now wait a second
if climate change is already here
and we're out of time and there's no way
to prevent it
then i guess there's no point talking
about it
so so even climate change that old
democrat boogeyman
even that
doesn't look like it can save joe biden
because because it's too late it's over
it's not just joe biden in trouble
california governor gavin newsom may get
thrown out of office the head of the
largest lgbt lobby just got ousted over
a sex scandal just like a previous head
of the lgbt lobby and dr fauci
is facing potential criminal charges i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from mary jane
chambers
who observes when harris said that she
and biden are people of faith
she didn't say which faith well that's
the key you have hit on the key here
because everybody's got to serve
somebody everybody is a person of faith
the question is
which
faith
to whom do you say your prayers at night
and what do you do after you say your
prayers at night if you're asking me
i check out my pillow my pillow is a
good conservative patriotic company
i like them for a lot of us like them
for that
but their products are so great
i think i would support them even if
they were run by the taliban i would
that's how good their products are you
all know about the the pillows but what
about the giza dream bed sheets they
look and feel great
means a great night's sleep they're
founded
right from the world's
best cotton it's called giza ultra soft
breathable durable they come with a
60-day money-back guarantee they come
with a 10-year warranty it could be
100-year warranty you're not going to
return them they're that great they come
in a variety of sizes and colors my
pillow's latest incredible deal it's the
sale of the year for a limited time
you'll receive 50 off the geese of dream
sheets you'll receive a set for as low
as
49.99 i love all my my pillow products
head on over right now mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square use
promo code daily wire there you will
find not only this amazing offer but
deep discounts on all my pillow products
the mattress top or the my pillow towel
set so much more you can call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code dailywire
or just go to mypillow.com make sure you
use promo code wire
joe biden cannot even fear monger on the
sun monster correctly the the way you
fearmonger on the sun monster is you you
always say
that the devastating effects are just a
little bit into the future and we can
still prevent them but time's running
out they've been saying this since the
1970s and they've changed the specifics
about what's going to happen so
initially it was going to be an ice age
and it was global cooling and but
there's still a little bit of time but
time is running out and then it became
global warming and it's going to get
really really hot and but time is
running out and then it became climate
change which was unfalsifiable and it
was it's going to happen in 12 years 10
years prince charles said it was going
to happen in 18 months he said that
several years ago so i guess we're
already past the point of no return
according to to prince charles aoc is a
little bit smarter than the future king
of england uh she she put it a little
bit further into the future so i think
we're still what eight or nine years
away from the aoc apocalypse but joe
biden you can't even do it right he puts
it in the past he says we're already out
of time well if we're already out of
time then who cares buster
well
joe biden cannot even
name
the sorts of extreme weather that he's
fearmongering about
you know the
looks like a tornado they don't call
them that anymore
that hit the crops and and wetlands in
the middle of the country and
in iowa and nevada and i mean it's just
across the board
now listen i know that political
correctness is getting extreme i know
that we're changing all of the words i
just wrote a book on it
but we can't
we can't call tornadoes tornadoes
anymore what what do we have to call
them
some have suggested it's it'll be like
torn tornadex
you know like they did with latino and
letting latinx it's going to be
tournaments
you just take away all of the vowels and
then you've got but i don't know what
what is he thinking of he's not thinking
of very much is the problem with him
so the climate change thing is not going
to work
afghanistan obviously that's a terrible
issue for the democrats all of these
issues are really not working one other
area where they're trying to fear monger
a little bit
is abortion they're really focusing in
on texas
which they have acknowledged to be the
sacrament
of liberalism that's why they're teaming
up with the satanic temple in texas but
it
it's not just joe biden who's messing up
this fear-mongering even the new york
times did that
the new york times are trying to scare
everyone into submission over the
abortion law but they're actually as
they do it they're undermining their own
argument i've got to give credit here to
mary margaret olahan over at the daily
caller
have you have you ever heard a more
beautifully catholic name than that mary
margaret ola that's a beautiful catholic
name
she pointed out something
right when this article came out and i
can't believe it got past the copy
editors this is a new york times article
talking about the democrats expanding
the welfare system
from cradle to grave democrats moved to
expand the social safety net now here's
right underneath the headline
the 3.5 trillion dollar social policy
bill that lawmakers begin drafting this
week would touch virtually every
american at every point in life from
conception to old age
you catch that
so the argument the argument for
abortion is
that
the baby is not a baby
the fetus is not a human life even if
the fetus becomes a human life in the
third trimester say or even oh my gosh
we're gonna be really conciliatory we're
gonna say it's in the second tribe
certainly
it's not at the point of conception why
then
the the the baby as you call it he's
just a zygote he's a clump of cells he's
non-human he's non-living
don't you dare call that a human life
unless you're the new york times and you
accidentally slip up
every point in life
from conception
which is now
the new york times is acknowledging
which is a part of life
okay so we've established that the
unborn baby from the very moment of
conception all the way back before he
was the tiniest little zygote right at
that moment
is a life
what kind of life is is he a giraffe
is he
a
platypus
no he's a human
so the new york times frame this put
this on your wall
i mean they're probably going to just
stealth change the headline and not tell
anybody about it but
we should frame this up the new york
times admits
human life begins at the moment
of conception
so now they're in this problem they're
saying yeah we acknowledge human life
begins at the moment of conception we
just think you ought to be able to kill
innocent people the most vulnerable
people among us that's what joe biden
said by the way that's his official line
now he says look
or rather i'm sorry that
that was his official line until about a
week ago
his official line was i believe that
life begins at the moment of conception
i accept that you're just teaching on
this but i think we should still be able
to kill the babies
only last week did he descend into
formal heresy and say i don't agree
with the church on that it's a
scientific reality though even the times
admits it speaking of scientific reality
do you remember
it was about a month or two ago
rand paul grilled dr fauci specifically
over whether or not dr fauci had funded
or supported in any way
gain of function research
period but specifically in the wuhan
institute of virology where the
coronavirus sprang from
gain to function research is where you
take naturally occurring viruses and
beef them up
make them deadlier make them more
transmissible
dr fauci says
absolutely not
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entire entirely
and completely incorrect
that the nih has not ever and does not
now
fund
gain of function research in the wuhan
institute do they find dr barrick
we do not fund do you find dr barracks
kane of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain or
function research and if it is it's
according to the guidelines and it is
being conducted in north carolina i
don't think it's concerning a bat virus
spike protein that he got from the wuhan
institute into the sars viruses gain of
function that is not a minority because
at least 200 scientists have signed a
statement from the cambridge working
group saying that it is gain of function
well it is not and if you look at the
grant
and you look at the progress reports it
is not
gained a function now you could tell
that she's real nervous here you could
you could hear it because he messes up
his grammar he said
it is does not and it if it and he also
has an error in logic here where he says
we are not funding gain of function
research
and all the gain of function research
we're funding is totally fine
you say well hold on which is it
you're not
you're not funding it or well if you
know look and maybe look we're not doing
it but even if we were it'd be north
carolina
well there's a new report out from the
intercept
that says
that that basically nothing in fouchy's
statement was true
he lied through his teeth they funded
gain of function research they funded it
at the wuhan institute of virology
you know we're talking about
specific matters
of life here
and so makes perfect sense that we ought
to talk about 40 days for life with the
left now totally in defense of abortion
talking about it constantly because of
this texas law i think a lot of us find
ourselves in heated debate sometimes
with our friends or our family or our
co-workers well 40 days for life has
just released the perfect book for those
looking to arm themselves against a
broad range of pro-abortion talking
points
this book is called what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion
this book is an easy read for people
looking to defend life and convert
hearts a whole lot has changed since the
supreme court invented the fictional
right to abortion in 1973 what to say
when equips readers with proven
approaches to dismantling the abortion
agenda these methods have already
enabled 40 days for life members to
convert the hearts of 221 abortion
workers how incredible is that know
exactly what to say and not to say when
abortion comes up balance converting
hearts with winning arguments and go on
the offensive instead of the defensive
it's an invaluable and timely tool get
your copy now what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world get free
shipping and 21 off a signed hardback at
40daysforlife.com
what to say when
rand paul grills dr fauci puts him on
the spot he says did you fund gain of
function research never no not in the
wood institute not anywhere maybe north
carolina but really not anywhere it
didn't happen no way no no how
the intercept
just filed a freedom of information act
request
it learned through the documents that
were released that the nih national
institutes of health issued a bat
coronavirus grant to a group called the
eco health alliance this was for 3.1
million dollars it included 599 thousand
dollars that the wuhan institute of
virology
used in part to identify and alter bat
coronaviruses
that were likely to infect humans
this is really bad for dr fauci in the
words of i mean you don't need to take
my word for it well i'm not an
epidemiologist you know i'm not an
expert but dr richard ebright who is a
molecular biologist at rutgers took a
look at these documents he said quote
the documents make it clear
that assertions by the nih director
francis collins and the niaid director
anthony fauci
that the nih did not support gaming
function research or potential pandemic
pathogen enhancement at the wuhan
institute of virology
are
untruthful
that was a very
diplomatic
way of saying
fauci lied
he lied about his role
in
starting the coronavirus
epidemic potentially
he lied about his role and why did he
lie
if
the
gain of function research
going on if identifying the
transmissible bat coronaviruses at the
wuhan institute of virology if that had
nothing to do
with the outbreak of kovid then why
would fauci lie about it on national
television at the u.s capitol before a
committee of the united states senate
why lie why try to cover it up
seems pretty bad
speaking of scandals there's another
tough scandal for a very prominent
democrat for a very prominent left
winger
this is from the hrc the human rights
campaign the human rights campaign is
one of these ridiculously named
organizations
that is focused specifically on
redefining marriage and then they did
redefine marriage then they moved on to
transgender stuff it's the the
organization that has the equal sign as
the logo and they really brilliantly
redefined the debate over marriage from
a question of what is marriage to a
question of who has the right to get
married
presuming their own conclusion that
sexual difference has nothing to do with
marriage so they were really brilliant
about it they were very effective in
getting marriage to be redefined
the head of that organization now is has
been fired
alfonso david he was fired as the
president of arc
because of a sex scandal
and unfortunately for this guy it wasn't
even his own sex gamble
it was another guy's sex scandal
this guy alfonso david was implicated in
assisting former new york governor
andrew cuomo
in his attempts to smear the women who
accused him of sexual misconduct
not good
when the head of the sexual liberation
organization gets caught up in a sex
scandal but this isn't the first time
that this has happened to the human
rights campaign this actually happened
with the founder of the human rights
campaign a guy by the name of terry bean
mr bean in 2014 was charged with sodomy
and sex abuse of a 15 year old boy
mr bean significantly older than 15
years old
now
this was a bad story so the media
covered it up at the time a few years
ago it looked like he might get off the
hook for this even though there it
looked as though there was first going
to be a settlement between the victim
and this guy
then
it looked like he was maybe going to get
off the hook but then he was he was
brought up again on the same charges and
then all of his claims of innocence i
think fell apart when in 2019 september
2019 bean's former sexual partner was
found again not the 15 year old but the
other one his older one i was found
guilty of third degree sodomy and third
degree sexual abuse
which even the oregonian reported at the
time as a blow to bean's claims of
innocence
um
so so he was supposed to be put on trial
then the trial was then postponed
they're dragging this thing out because
he's politically a very important person
for democrats this is bad stuff
this is not good
you do because the the human rights i
mean it's
i think perfectly good for justice that
this guy be brought up on on what he did
but it's really not good for the
democrats
facade for the the lobbying efforts for
the human rights campaign and for the
left more broadly because they've got to
put out this image that they are the
moral ones they're the good ones they're
the clean and squeaky clean and they're
not they keep going down on similar
scandals which brings me to
a topic it's very politically incorrect
i'm not supposed to talk about it
conservatives are not supposed to raise
any objection to this we're just
supposed to move on and it's supposed to
be totally fine because we don't want to
seem like meanies or anything like that
but i have to talk about it there was a
tweet that came out last week from p
buddha judge
mayor pete the man who was almost
president now he's transportation
secretary and it's pete but a judge and
his partner jason and they're lying in a
hospital bed holding two newborn babies
why are they in a hospital these are
babies that they it's it's unclear if
they've adopted the babies or if they
the babies were produced in some other
way they're lying in a hospital bed
which is very strange because they
didn't i don't think they gave birth i
don't listen i told i'm no
epidemiologist i'm no biologist but it
would seem strange to me
if they gave birth so
pete tweets out jason and i are beyond
thankful for all the kind wishes since
first sharing the news that we're
becoming parents we're delighted to
welcome penelope rose and joseph august
buddhagej to our family
okay we're supposed to say this is
totally awesome this is wonderful
don't raise any questions about it but
we have to raise questions about it i
understand why people don't want to even
why many conservatives don't want to
because pete seems like a nice guy you
know they say they seem like perfectly
right upstanding citizens they just want
to be happy they look so happy
we're pro-life aren't we so it's good
and let's just not i don't we we don't
want to seem like jerks right so
but we do
have to think more seriously
about bioethics here okay
because
in making pete and chasen happy
we are robbing two babies of their
mother either of their natural mother or
of a potential adoptive mother don't
forget in this country there are an
estimated 36 couples
for every who are attempting to adopt
for every one baby put up for adoption
there is no shortage of couples trying
to adopt in this country okay
there is a shortage of people who want
to adopt older children who were say
taken out of abusive homes or you know
children who are 12 or 13 years old who
are in foster care that's a separate
issue we're talking about infants babies
there were 36 couples trying to adopt
every baby there
and now there is a battle going on
between whether or not you're allowed to
take into consideration the
circumstances of the potential
adoptive parents
is there a distinction to be made
between
a husband and a wife who are married
and a single mother for instance
should
both of those
types of people be treated equally when
they're trying to adopt i don't think so
i think it's better for the baby to have
a mother and a father
what about a mother and a father and a
mother and a mother or a mother and a
father and a father and a father should
both of those
types of couples be treated equally i
don't think so because i think men and
women actually are different and i think
both actually have something to
contribute to raising a child
and i think that
we erase women or we erase men when we
say it doesn't matter there's there's no
difference it's all just the same you're
just parent number one and parent number
two
and furthermore there's no evidence that
they actually adopted we don't know that
it's adoption it may have just been that
they went through a
clinical process of in vitro
fertilization whereby they shopped for
an egg and they purchased an egg from
one woman and then they rented the womb
of another woman and then they
intentionally deprived a child of his
natural mother two children potentially
that's really bad too folks and i'm glad
that it put a smile on pete buddha
judge's face i i actually am i'm not
even i'm not even being facetious here
but
there are other bioethical concerns here
and what when we just accept this
willy-nilly what we are saying
effectively is
there's no role for a mother in a
child's life it's all just the same
there's no difference between men and
women
and okay sure maybe the child will never
never get to hold his mother and anyone
who's ever had a kid can see the
difference okay between a kid reacting
to his mother and a kid reacting to his
father and he needs both and it's a
fallen world and sometimes a mother dies
and sometimes a father dies and
sometimes kids are robbed of these
things but we don't need to encourage
that
certainly not to satisfy our own
longings that that
for whatever reason
or are not being fulfilled
that that is that is not an ethical
thing to do that's not a moral thing to
do
and as i guess this relates to the
abortion debate in as much as it's very
easy to ignore what is best for
someone who cannot express himself like
an unborn baby or like a little a little
newborn baby for that matter but we
really ought to take that into
consideration
unfortunately our society doesn't think
that way anymore that's not that's not
the way we look and and
increasingly
the society is very intolerant
of the traditional viewpoints of
basically everyone on earth that says
maybe this isn't the best thing
we can't see clearly
because we don't have blue blocks
glasses i love blue blocks
blue one not only because they make me
look like rachel maddow but because uh
blue blocks
block the blue light that damages our
eyes and that can lead to digital eye
strain seriously i i no longer
in almost any circumstance we'll look at
a screen that's got blue light coming
out all the time it's a real problem it
leads to a lot of eye strain blurred
vision headaches dry watery eyes don't
do it this can cause anxiety depression
low energy i know it sounds crazy but
just trust me try out blue blocks they
are evidence-backed they're made under
optics laboratory conditions in
australia
they're created with high quality lenses
for daytime nighttime and color therapy
exactly in line with the suggested
peer-reviewed academic literature
they got over 40 frames so if you don't
want the mat out you can get you get
another one too they come with a
prescription uh go to blueblocks.com
knowles right now use promo code knowles
at checkout get 20 off and enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks get
your energy back sleep better block out
the unhealthy effects of blue light be
just like me
with blue blocks b l u b l o x dot com
slash knowles or click the link below
make sure you use code knowledge to get
20 off your order free shipping on
orders over 115 bucks b l u b l o x dot
com slash knowles for 20 off today also
you got to subscribe to morningwire
right now subscribe and start listening
to morningwire on applespotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear it's a terrific show we'll be right
back with a lot more
the european union right now is
threatening to withhold 150 million
dollars from poland
and it's all over this same issue that
keeps cropping up
the sexual revolution
so poland recently a number of areas in
poland areas and towns have said that
they're free of the lgbtq ideology
they're not saying they're free of gay
people they're not saying they're
they're persecuting
you people who have different sexual
desires and and behaviors and things
like that they're just saying the lgbt
ideology the ideology that says that
there's no difference between men and
women the ideology that says that you
must pursue any desire you have
whatsoever the ideology that says that
you're not allowed to hold anything
resembling a traditional view of
marriage or sexuality we're ridding
ourselves of that
in favor of something else
poland is a catholic country
traditionally
at the fall of the soviet union what was
one of the big events that caused the
fall of the soviet union pope john paul
ii shows up and in this soviet occupied
awful you know
poor oppressed people
million people show up and said chant we
want god we want god this is a place
this is a place that has been saving
western civilization going back to the
battle of vienna at least okay and what
they're saying is look we we have this
view that's a christian view and so we
don't want to have the view that's this
radical leftist view
and now the european union which is a
liberal empire it's not a christian
empire it's a liberal empire
he's saying okay then we're going to cut
you off 150 million euro we're not we're
not doing it
this is
relating to what we were talking about
with afghanistan okay there were a lot
of conservatives who said we should pull
out of afghanistan because we don't know
what we're doing there
what are we doing and it brought up a
debate over nationalism versus
imperialism are we just going to focus
at home are we going to spread our
empire abroad
and then even on the empire what is our
empire
i think it's a liberal empire i think
it's about
you know
pride flags in kandahar
i think it's about that's that's what it
became it became about all these sort of
liberal
ideas
and
people don't like that
afghanistan i don't think likes that
very much
the taliban certainly don't like that i
think the taliban are finally going to
lose the support of liberals
do you know why not because of what
they're doing to
women or not even not because of what
they're doing to americans or anything
like that
they committed an unforgivable sin
the taliban
painted over a mural of george floyd
they did oh you oh you're
we're probably gonna end up nuking the
taliban before the day is through you
can't you can do a lot but you can't
paint over a mural of george st george
no
there
there's actually
a very good reason why they're painting
over the mural i mean it's funny that
it's ridiculous that there are murals to
george floyd but
the reason they're painting over the
mural is because george floyd is a is a
symbol of western imperialism
crazy as that is to say
george floyd
and the rainbow flag which they flew
over the embassy in kabul those are the
new symbols of western empire and we
think that's weird here in the west
because in many ways those are symbols
that are meant to undermine the
christian west
the the
george floyd mural the blm ideology is a
an ideology that states that the west is
evil
right the pride flag is a
is a symbol that says that
christianity is wrong it's a symbol that
says that our traditional views of sex
are wrong
and yet
those are both still symbols of the west
they're not associated with any other
civilization and they're making
universal claims about every place on
earth including
afghanistan which is why they don't like
it
no doubt cnn is going to accuse the
taliban
of white supremacy they they these
these pashtun militants they're such
white supremacist and white supremacists
well they actually are making that
argument indirectly right now
cnn had a peace out this is a real doozy
i don't recommend people go look at cnn
usually but you gotta you gotta look at
this one
white supremacy
with a tan
that's the title of it you saw the the
first volley a couple of weeks ago when
the la times called
larry elder the black face of white
supremacy
and now cnn is getting on board and
they're saying
that
white supremacy is just
so embedded in the fabric of america
that
even when black people get a lot of
political power more than they have now
it will still be white supremacy they
said quote
don't ever underestimate white
supremacy's ability to adapt the
assumption that more racial diversity
equals more racial equality is a
dangerous myth
racial diversity can function as a
cloaking device
concealing the most powerful forms of
white supremacy while giving the
appearance of racial progress racism
will likely be just as entrenched in a
brown or america as it is now it will
still be white supremacy with a tan
so you see
even if
every political office is held by black
people
even if whites are second or third class
citizens
even if
america knocks down every statue of
every white person and all the statues
are black even then
it will be white supremacy
white supremacy
through black people
this is sort of like joe biden's climate
change claim
right joe biden says look we're it's
climate change is so bad we can't even
stop it if climate change is already
here we're living in it
oh okay then who cares then who cares
there's nothing to do
right it's joe biden undermining his own
argument okay there's not that's just
the way it is there is it is
unfixable irredeemable it's done okay
all right then whatever man weight off
my shoulders i don't need to worry about
recycling anymore or anything because
it's already here so who cares
i guess the same is true of white
supremacy
there is according to cnn
literally nothing you can do you can
kill all the white people you can give
all of their property and all of their
power to black people it will still be
white supremacy okay so i'm just not
worried about it then
because there's nothing we can do
of course i mean it's preposterous
but this actually
the phrase critical race theory is
somewhat overused but this is a good
example of critical race theory because
critical race theory is a marxist
lens to attack all of american and
really western history and it's really
tied up also in in economics so so some
of the foundational essays of critical
race theory will say that
our system of private property in the
united states is
part of white supremacy
right communist systems not white
supremacist but capitalism white
supremacist and they put that in the cnn
article too they say quote cuba also has
a complex history with race racism is
often described as a relic of capitalism
in the communist countries this is very
funny because cuba is pretty racist okay
i've visited cuba i love cuba but it's
you know they don't there's there are
sexual they're sexual there are racial
tensions there
as well but it's a communist country and
it has been for 60 years so huh what's
going on there oh okay it's
that's why it's the relic of capitalism
oh okay all the bad stuff is a relic of
capitalism all the good stuff is part of
communism all the bad stuff in society
is white people even when there are no
white people left and all the the good
stuff is black people even if white
people did some of it okay
okay that makes sense
okay
is this persuading anybody is anybody
looking at this article and saying yes
larry elder he is he is a klansman
he is just like robert byrd senator byrd
who was a democrat but who was secretly
a republican probably
does anyone buy that i can't imagine
that they do and i i think the democrats
actually are getting a little bit
nervous here gavin newsom
facing you know a recall
threat from that black face of white
supremacy
last month he spent
more than 36 million dollars fighting
this recall effort this included a ton
of tv ads i'm talking to my friends who
are who are in california
they're being inundated with gavin
newsom ads a lot of phone banking a lot
of door knocking
a lot of texting
the five top republicans who are running
to replace newsome
and the pro recall committees
combined
spent less than a third as much
over the same period of time they also
face certain limits on their spending
whereas gavin newsom does not that's one
way in which the election is rigged
so he obviously is
worried
as he should be and by the way there are
so much rigging going on right now in
the california election so you've seen
the ballots that went out with holes
poked in them and the holes are
presumably or ostensibly for sorting
purposes or whatever
for some
security measure that eludes a lot of
people
but the way that the circles that are
punched out are aligned on the envelope
they go exactly over
the yes circle for yes recall governor
news so if someone votes to recall
newsom
in many cases you can see it from from
the outside the envelope
just a coincidence i'm sure right
i i know many people personally who have
gotten multiple ballots
because of widespread automatic mail-in
in this election i think i i got a
ballot i believe
a number of my friends have moved to
tennessee who who have requested not to
receive a bell they've received ballots
too because the democrats are trying to
cheat and even still they're terrified
they're going to lose why because
the democrats generally are collapsing
in terms of public opinion joe biden's
approval ratings
are in free fall in
not just not just nationally but in
seven
key
congressional districts
this is a really bad this is according
to a poll from the american action
network
uh that that americans are really not
pleased with this and seven key
districts is very important because
we're not just looking at
the recall in california right now we're
not just looking at 2024.
we're looking at 2022.
if republicans can take back
that house
and hopefully the senate but even just
the house
then then much of the biden agenda is
dead the most radical aspects of it are
dead much like some have suggested the
president seems to be
it's over there's no there's no chance
that they will pass
so so this is their last shot to make
things happen and unfortunately the
democrats agenda right now is not very
popular
now the the key question is going to be
will the elections be fair will they be
free will they be fair in 2022. the
elections were not fair in 2020 the
democrats rigged the elections by taking
away election integrity measures
okay even the republicans who say it was
not stolen nothing was stolen don't ever
say it was stolen it was totally fair
but you know biden got all every all the
votes in the history of the world even
those republicans were very insistent
that the election was not stolen
we'll admit
especially if you ask them privately it
was obviously rigged
in pennsylvania they violated the state
constitution to conduct the election
they sent out the widespread mail on
votes which even obama said is is a
grave threat to election integrity some
places poll watchers were not allowed a
ton of access the the the count was
halted it was strange it took days and
weeks there was double counting that
went on just in georgia just in the one
place we looked for it
so yeah there were big problems of
course
good news on that front too texas just
passed an election integrity bill
the bill
uh it just instituted a ban on
drive-through voting just instituted a
ban on around the clock voting added an
id requirement for mail-in and absentee
ballots that's good established a
training program for poll watchers who
can now be more active in monitoring the
process they don't have to just stay
locked in their chair
it requires the texas secretary of state
to maintain consistently updated voter
rolls so that when people leave texas
very few people are doing that today
anyway
but you see in california when people
leave
a state
they're not permitted to continue to
receive a vote
to continue to receive a ballot this is
good if anything i think that this
election integrity bill is a little too
modest i wish it went much further what
it did is restore
common sense election integrity measures
that we had even a couple years ago in
most places
but it's a good start
if we can have measures like that
throughout the country
then i think that it'll be much harder
for democrats to cheat i think if the
election is free and fair in 2022 i
think republicans are going to do
extremely well
even on the allegedly controversial
issues
like the texas abortion law even on
those issues
the republican policies are pretty
popular there's another poll out you
know i'm always skeptical of polls
especially because most polls skew
democrat because
so social science and statistics
generally skews in that direction
it comes from the statistics comes from
statism right from
the state but
neither here nor there i'm happy to cite
polls when they back up what i'm what
i'm hoping for and there's a poll in
texas that shows that the plurality of
voters support the texas abortion law
according to a rasmussen survey
rasmussen is a right-leaning pole firm
but they got a great record a plurality
of voters support the pro-life law in
texas so that's 46
support the law
compared to 43 percent who oppose the
law this is mostly on party lines so 70
of republicans support it 69 of
democrats oppose it and the plurality of
independence supported as well 44 so
we're not saying it's the majority it'd
be better if it were the majority but it
is the plurality
in terms of opinions on the law
the pro-life
the pro-life pro-pro-life law position
contains the most
people
and so in that environment
the left's only
option is to censor to censor and cheat
and that's what they're doing right now
twitter just suspended the official
press account of jd vance jd vance is
running for senate in ohio he's running
on a very
trad conservative platform i don't know
how else to put it he's the author of
hillbilly elegy and he's ditching the
kind of chamber of commerce
wall street
you know just lower taxes and
let the left run the culture kind of
talking points that we've heard from
republicans over recent decades he's
leaning much more into social issues
much more into cultural issues much more
into
a working class appeal
people are accusing jd vance being
inauthentic here i'm not making a
comment one one way or the other i'm
just pointing out
that's where his campaign is going and
the left sees that as the genuine threat
the left is not threatened by
libertarians the left is not threatened
by neoconservatives they're just not
because in many ways they share this
they all share the same premises the
left is threatened by a traditional
conservative appeal to the american
people to the to the american worker in
particular so they boot him off jd's
personal account is still up there but
the press account is gone jd says no
warning no explanation of what rules i
allegedly broke but this is what happens
when we allow five companies to control
what we're allowed to say
and he's right
he's right and you kind of knew that
this would happen by the way so there
are the court jester conservatives the
the dweebs who say well just build your
own twitter well what if you you don't
like that google is controlling all of
the speech in our public square um well
maybe you should build your own google
even though google by the way is is like
part of the government
okay the google and the government have
many business interests together they
the government has helped to fund parts
of google
google is operating as a sort of proxy
arm of the government
especially with regard to censorship
so if you run for office but you don't
threaten any of the entrenched interests
even as a republican you're probably
fine
you're a clown but you're you know
you'll be fine in terms of pushback but
if you run and you actually threaten
these companies and these entrenched
interests then they're going to go after
you
jd put it well he said i'm a senate
candidate in ohio this was my campaign
account to me this is election
interference a multinational corporation
making it harder for me to communicate
with the people of ohio absolutely true
you saw this happen on january 7th
when twitter
and facebook and google
censored even the duly elected sitting
president of the united states showing
where power really lies in this country
an important part of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i also have to mention another
book by the way this has been a big year
for me and books with words
before that i was only focused on books
without words but uh now i'm focused on
books with words i i was very honored to
be asked to write the introduction to
god and man at yale god and man at yale
the first book by william f buckley jr
it is widely credited with starting the
conservative movement it's an attack on
atheism and communism in the academy
it's sort of the og book on this topic
this subtitle is the superstitions of
academic freedom it's a it's a terrific
book and i was very very honored to be
able to to write the introduction to the
70th anniversary edition
to me
this this is very encouraging for the
conservative movement because it shows
that i think that the conservative
movement broadly is recognizing the
errors of the past couple decades we're
saying we need to return to tradition we
need to return to a more muscular beefy
substantive conservatism and so i'm i'm
really honored and happy to be part of
that you can get that book right now
amazon is not really letting it show up
in the search results too much
so if you want to get it i've got links
on my twitter and and things like that
but you can also if you search it on
amazon god and man at yale uh just when
you
order the search click you know instead
of pre you know order price low to high
price high to low price order you know
average reviews click on newest arrivals
and then that'll pop up to the top it's
shipping right now really happy to do it
great great admirer of bill buckley so
i'm really pleased about all of that
uh so that's that's where the
conservative movement stands very
excited very encouraging but we've still
got a huge uphill battle because the
left is going to try to cheat though
we're fighting back on that with
election integrity laws the left is
going to try to censor we're fighting
back on that by trying to rein in these
corporations finally will we be
successful we'll find out
and the other way they try to cheat
is
by flooding the country with illegal
aliens
but even that is not going particularly
well for democrats
it's it's difficult to date and identify
the remains of people who died trying to
sneak into our country
but
it appears that 2020
the last year of the trump
administration was the deadliest year in
the history of the southern border
until
this past year
the the border patrol agents have have
already found 253 people near the u.s
mexico border
that's uh
that was last year rather this year that
they've already found just through july
they found 383 people that's 151 percent
increase the year isn't even close to
done yet
that's really bad news for biden because
at least trump was trying to reduce the
number of illegal aliens coming through
joe biden is trying to increase it he's
encouraging people to come across and
has encouraged people to come across
and we're this is supposed to be nice
right this is supposed to be
compassionate doesn't look compassionate
to me
you've got the decomposing bodies
of
illegal aliens coming through desperate
people coming through because crass and
opportunistic and cynical politicians
like joe biden are calling for it do you
think that's going to look good
i don't think so i think it's another
optics failure for the biden
administration and it's an optics
failure because
not because it's giving the appearance
of something it isn't true it's because
we're seeing the reality of what these
policies look like
a total
failure on every
count
really bad news for biden sad for
america right now but potentially
encouraging for the future i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles shall see
you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show